hello Kardashian fans haters and the
like I'm Lauren Zima and I'm Danny
direct oh we are here counting down the
biggest Kardashian moments of 2016 there
were so many so many you guys they were
dubbed America's first family in the
past that was very controversial but
here's the thing you guys click on him
we talk about him we got to go over
their biggest moments of the year
because they pretty much owned the year
as they do every year and so many of
them had headlines throughout the year
for sure but we gotta kick things off
with the biggest o Kim Kardashian and
Kanye West I mean what a saga this year
for that what a saga and by the way you
guys I want to say we know you're gonna
have comments on all of the Kardashian
moments you guys always have strong
opinions on this crew so leave them on e
t--'s Facebook page and we will get them
on our phones and talk him through so
Kim and Kanye the saga that's what we
dubbed it of course last year at the end
of last year Kim gave birth to st.
weselton
the beginning of this year was focusing
on her body getting her body back Kim
revealed that she lost an amazing 60
pounds I have to say as a woman I loved
Kim's weight loss journey I mean girl
working it on snapchat all oiled up
there for one reason or another probably
a photo shoot um Kim showed more of her
body this year I think than ever before
I mean she posted her playboy years ago
but through social media through
snapchat especially she really
chronicled this weight loss and she was
really up friend about how she did it
she showed herself working out she
admitted that she was doing Atkins she
was going no carb and she said that she
wanted to get back down to her weight
like before she'd oh the nude selfie I
was gonna say because she wanted to
flaunt that new bod and broke the
internet once again with this naked
selfie and you know what a lot of people
were an uproar you know it is so funny
about it remember Kim was like that was
an old picture I just threw it up a Kim
has said that she is the one doing all
of her social media and I believe it
because it's so authentically her and I
think that's why it resonates you know
what Kim does what she wants to do but
it was crazy to think about how many
celebrities were actually so against the
polarizing and they were so vocal about
it too but of course because Kim is a
boss now
that she has two children she goes I can
say anything I want she clapped back at
her haters on Twitter she called out
Bette Midler she called out Chloe Moretz
but listen look at this tweet this is my
favorite I had to pull up this one it
I'm gonna read to you guys sorry I'm
late to the party guys I was busy
cashing my 80 million video game check
and transfering 53 million into our
joint account okay mic drop mic drop Kim
uh yes like you said she had to shut
down so many haters because this selfie
was controversial because a lot of
people argued and a lot of celebrities
argued that Kim is this powerful female
figure and that she needed to set a good
example but you know Kim comes out of
this hey my body I'm gonna do what I
want to do owning her sexuality and I
saw both sides of it but I gotta say it
my love to Kim on this one do you want
to do girl you look great and you know
what I'll go say if you got it flaunt it
I don't think because you have kids that
automatically it automatically makes you
not sexy anymore but like you said we
sort of had to Chronicle every step of
the back and forth the Chloe grace
Moretz is and Bette Midler's in Kim's
response we were writing a new article
every five seconds it felt like for this
and that also happened with her hubby
Kanye West and his various Twitter rants
we would literally you guys have our
article ready to go and he would tweet
again and weren't you know were we're
accustomed to Kanye Twitter rants we are
but then this one was epic this was
against a Twitter rant against Wiz
Khalifa fellow rapper uh you know he
went on the defensive and it was kind of
random basically this is based on after
Kanye wanted to change the name of his
album to waves
Wiz Khalifa was not having it said
please don't take waves don't know what
that's about but economy wasn't having
it and he just went on a crazy Twitter
rant I mean it range from claiming that
Wiz Khalifa stole from Kid Cudi uh he
also I was referring to his ex Amber
Rose who happens to be Wiz Khalifa's
baby mama saying that a stripper trapped
you I mean and even he will even have
the audacity to say that like I am
control of your kids it was kind of
crazy it was crazy and we got to talk
about the tweet that made it the
craziest Amber Rose
amber Rose's tweet you guys was gonna
take that she wasn't gonna take it of
course look at this all kanye west's are
you matter
are you mad I'm not around I can't even
say it to play in your home anymore
hashtag fingers in the booty ass [ __ ] I
mean you want to talk about a mic drop
the clap back heard around the world
I I think I squealed we all it was like
everyone in the office got that tweet
emailed to them at the exact same moment
and we all audibly ah did you see this
it was who says that 2016 was the year
of bold social media celebrity arguments
and I was intrigued by and I was
captivated the booty s [ __ ] might be
like I don't even know what that means
I'll be honest I don't even know NAT me
register at it it was the year of so
many makeups and breakups I mean now at
this point by the end of 2016 amber and
Kanye are cool because blac chyna is
Amber's best friend blac Chyna's with
Rob we're gonna get to that but they're
pretty cool but shortly after that amber
actually met with Kim yes and they took
a photo together which also lost the
internet so their bygones be bygones
right this is like Shakespearean tragedy
Odyssey epicness this family so another
little bit of a quarrel for Kanye him
and Taylor Swift Taylor Swift argued
first we thought they're gonna make up
there at the Grammys together they're
cool they're posing for the first time
together after their VMA beef years ago
and then Kanye releases his song famous
and in it he says of Taylor I made that
be famous Taylor Swift gets on stage at
this year's Grammys to an album of the
year and kind of calls out Kanye in
front of the world oh my god what's
crazy about that is I get why she wanted
to use a big platform to kind of call
him out on it but girl you just want
album of the year your second time
you're the first woman to win out under
twice and you took that moment and made
it something else which kind of sucks
I definitely see what you're saying I
mean I I think she was trying to really
come at it hard I'm guessing by using
that platform but also you know it you
know it came across a little bit like
you don't want to come across petty
either you know so
and of course that's not where it ended
you think it would just be over after
that
yes No things got worse I know you know
Kanye claimed he actually asked Taylor
for permission to use that lyric
Taylor's reps strongly denied that and
then Kim Kardashian got a little
snapchat happy with her savagery she
released the alleged phone calls between
Taylor and Kanye talking about famous
and let the whole world judge for
themselves the whole world you know and
then I think there even some arguments
some people saying those calls have been
edited I mean then Taylor releases her
statement on it through a screen shot of
her notes app it was so much this is why
we're calling it Kim and Kanye the saga
by the way you guys so many of your
comments coming in right now you guys
are kind of going back and forth in the
comments section I get what you're
saying there are a lot of polarizing
opinions here wanna get into then Kim
towards the end of this year we had
talked so much just in these last few
minutes about how Kim was on social
media being bold having this huge year
for her she joined snapchat she met with
snapchat like Kim was all about social
media this year more than ever before
but she has now gone silent because of
when she was robbed at gunpoint in Paris
just a few months ago we miss Kim yeah I
miss Kim a lot of action I missed him so
much here her and Kris and Kourtney that
was during Paris Fashion Week just
before she was robbed and kid
essentially kidnapped at gunpoint those
people the burglars still on the loose
it was it was just so wild that
something on that magnitude that kind of
crime could happen to such a well-known
Alister celebrity and it's obviously a
very very dangerous situation and no
matter your opinions on Kim this is a
mother of two it was held at gunpoint
for what jewelry so it's kind of crazy
that clearly it's affected her she
really has taking a cue from her brother
Robert Kardashian and has really
remained silent social media we hadn't
even seen her since no we actually we've
seen her we've gotten a few paparazzi
photos of her just out and about and
actually a mini TM I'm calm right now
there's an article about how Kim went to
a Christmas party last night so she is
still spending time with family you and
I were saying we missed that Kardashian
Christmas card we haven't seen their
Christmas cards that yet this year so
we'll see if we get it and if Kim's
gonna be in it but we miss you Kim as if
things couldn't get worse I
you see here's the thing about this
family you think that they have hit this
headline that how could they you know
compare to this
Kim robbed at gunpoint and then Kanye's
hospitalization happens I mean it's so
crazy to think that like the we thought
the robbery was enough right but of
course one source told et Kanye was
hospitalized for what they're calling a
mental breakdown while another source
told us it was due to exhaustion and
lack of sleep but no doubt
Kim's robbery I'm sure did not help no
and we had even heard from you know
sources and from people who are close to
Kim and Kanye we talked to John Legend
who's a friend of that of theirs for a
long time and he said you know Kanye has
been through a lot the robbery affected
him too it's the mother of his children
remember at the time he walked off on
stage in the middle of a show because of
what happened I mean he had some very
erotic behavior leading up and today I
had a lot of rants during his concert
yeah only now his friends Beyonce and
jay-z saying he supported Trump it was
all kind of leading up to this crazy
crazy crazy news and in fact we actually
spoke with Kris Jenner Kim's mom of
course right before we learned of his
hospitalization this is around the time
that he actually canceled his tour
take a look what she had to say now what
I can't tell from that is if she knew he
had been hospitalized at that point you
know from all that we know about the
hospitalization we have heard that it
was essentially like a moment where he
was at a friend's house and a doctor
called his doctor called 9-1-1 we heard
the 911 call and it's up on her website
and said like we just need some help
here right now you know so I think it
was maybe not an expected
hospitalization he wasn't even with
family at the time but we don't know for
sure necessary yeah and what I think is
so interesting about that clip is me and
you can see on Chris's face her face
kind of falls when she talks about it
she's like he's exhausted
you know she you can tell that she's
feeling that exhaustion for him she's so
close with her kids and with their
husbands she calls them her sons so you
could tell she felt it clearly there's a
lot going on behind the scenes I
actually saw Kanye's concert and it is
pretty grueling I will say light it's a
high energy he's giving it his all he's
chained to this high stage he's a solo
he's a soul it's just her it's literally
just him on the stage of course we've
seen him since then he took a private
meeting with Donald Trump I mean that
photo is of course we're calling it
rockin the blonde hair look at that
photo
I mean he's acarya tweeted that they
were meeting to discuss multicultural
issues so right if you have the power to
meet with a future president then I
guess you gotta kind of take that
opportunity I mean so we now know that
Kanye is out of hospitalization because
he met with our president-elect but
again who could have seen it coming you
guys your comments are continuing to
come in one of you Blum's says love the
Kardashians and the ones that claim they
don't you obviously are here commenting
about them it's so true you can't say
that people don't talk about this family
by the way you guys please tell us what
you think of Kanye's hospitalization and
then subsequent meeting with the
president-elect it's very interesting to
hear everybody's thoughts on this
because it is very I will say one more
thing about Kim and Kanye out of all of
this and especially after Kanye's
hospitalization our sources told tell us
that that's actually made them stronger
and closer together so there were rumors
of a divorce but our sources say that's
simply not true
who's the one person Kanye West falls on
Twitter Kim it's cute it's Kim just like
the guy is Queen there right or dies
clear-eyed or dies
alright well you mentioned we've got to
move on there's still so much to say
you mentioned Rob Kardashian and his
seclusion in the past 2016 was the year
of blac Chyna bring and Rob Kardashian
into the lights yes Rob is back come
back I mean he came back in a big way
really obviously once we learned that
they were dating I was pretty shocking
no given the family history blac chyna
of course is a mother to Tyga son who's
dating Kylie Jenner Rob's sister you
guys we've come so far since that
craziness that it is you know they've
now had baby dreams so I feel so past it
but if I think about where our minds
were earlier in this year we were just
trying to wrap our heads around the fact
like what would this family tree be
because Kylie dates Tyga Tyga had a
child with China and then China's gonna
get married to rob and have his baby and
so what if Kylie and Tyga get married
then like what does what are these
children's relations were blown that
this was real news I mean because of
that I think there was a lot of rumors
and speculation that there was some
stride but Turner strife between the
family and they weren't sure if blac
chyna wasn't being accepted thankfully
we spoke to her herself blac Chyna she
kind of set the record straight on how
the family is feeling and accepting her
take a look I feel like everybody is
entitled but
actually the engagement it was so fast
and it has happened and he didn't do
anything like malicious it wasn't to
hurt me by at all yeah and where were
you out with the fishes now we're all in
a good place and I'm happy and we're
excited for the new addition in my
family and in their family I mean again
the engagement and and then the
pregnancy the news of that came so so
fast I think was a lot of information
for them to to wrap their heads around
yes we saw it play out and keep Mia but
the Kardashians you know the girls on
their phones being like wait is Rob
engaged what's happening and their
relationship with Rob had been kind of
rough over the past year because he'd
been in seclusion he'd lived on and off
with Chloe him and Chloe are very close
but also had fights because of the way
he was living his life I mean can we
even talk about to the fact that blac
Chyna is amber Rose's best friend amber
who dated Kanye so Kim previously was
nan great term I mean the family tree
again it's so Shakespearean it's our
modern-day Shakespeare I'm gonna say
that I know it's bold you probably won't
agree I'm like no I am too following the
drama with eating my popcorn but again
Rob came back in a big way because of
that I think he was on Keeping Up with
the Kardashians this season I think he
was spending more time with his sisters
and of course they've missed him so I
think China and the baby have been
really good really good for Rob I mean
he has talked so much about the loss of
his father and what becoming a father
would mean to him you know when he just
instagrams about baby dream he seemed so
happy posting here he is that's the
picture when she was first born and he
even says she looks just like his dad
Robert Kardashian so I think that meant
a lot to him and it's been great to see
him just even be on social media you
know he really was a little over a year
ago we were like wondering when we would
even see photos of Rob necks because no
one had seen him and now he's on a
reality show so welcome back welcome
back to rob in 2016 by the way I was at
the event we showed a few minutes ago
with Robin China at the Tropicana that
blue background in um Las Vegas and they
didn't do interviews there that day but
man was it sweet to watch the way he was
with her he was so protective of her
like he let her do her thing he let her
hang out with her friends but then he
would go walk over and check on her and
I asked him like hey man are you guys
doing interview say and he just said I'm
know whatever she wants to do today he
was real
putting her first which is really sweet
hey you know what she also if you watch
Robin China which is so entertaining she
puts him in his place too she doesn't
let him get away with stuff you know and
I needs that structure and that
discipline I'm like I'm alive but they
seem so happy together so I'm happy I
want to say Joaquin just said I think
Khloe Kardashian had the best year she
has overcome so much and seems to be
thriving at this point
Joaquin we about to get to Khloe because
I could not agree more
let's real quick get him to Kylie
because Wow Kylie Jenner Kylie Kylie
Kylie her makeup line exploding this
year her relationship with Tyga on and
off she turned 18 she just had a year
where she became a superstar you know
it's a big deal or you're a big deal
when you're hosting the
kardashian-jenner Thanksgiving it was
our house she has become a makeup mogul
a little kim kardashian in the making
Kris Jenner in the main game good for
you 18 years old and just killing it
business-wise I think kylie is wise
beyond her years I really do she runs a
business I know that she has the help of
her mom and her sisters but we hear this
from celebrities a lot that when you
grow up in the public eye you kind of
age a little beyond your years and I
think that that has happened with Kylie
you know we see her taking care of King
and of dream and I wouldn't be surprised
what are you about to say if I wouldn't
be surprised if Kylie becomes a mom at a
young age she even said I don't have a
sort of Keeping Up with the Kardashians
she said she wanted to be a young mom
and have kids in her 20s I wouldn't be
surprised I'm sorry girl keep doing your
thing no honestly I'm sorry she should
know of course you see it but I seen it
seen it she built her life a little bit
more look at Kim took a while before Kim
settled down had the kids and so I hope
the same for Kylie Kylie can't afford a
nanny I'm just saying but she and Tyga
are going strong you know this past
month she actually took these sexy
pictures with him for his 27th birthday
I mean I'm glad they're on now so see
were the new year takes very sexy
pictures happy birthday oh my god all
right let's get into Miss Chloe K
because I could not be happier to talk
about her what a comeback here there it
is come back with a king she has had you
love Coco I love her she's my favorite
Kardashian as much as I love them all
Khloe has had a year of you know she
overcame everything with Lamar
they have finalized their divorce and we
wish the best to Lamar
I am just so happy to see Chloe thriving
dating other people her body looking
sick she is killing it with her denim
line at Khloe's just killing it
she did have a one rough patch of course
this was the year of kocktails with
khloé' which we were excited for it did
not go past the 1 season um you know we
drank to it and then we poured one hour
we pour one out for ya she's too busy
she's got other stuff she has to take
mean she's got her body right like she's
been so active in the gym and I I
mentioned that not from a place of
vanity but she said this is a place for
her of therapy and she's really taken
advantage of that she works out with her
new beau mr. Tristan Thompson so she's
you know doing things for herself which
i think is great yes she and Courtney
have both said you know Courtney will
get into went through a rough year with
her and Scott being on and off Khloe and
Kourtney of both said that working out
was so therapeutic for them kept them so
healthy we've seen them on snapchat just
killing it and next year we're gonna get
Khloe's revenge bod reality show which
will be so interesting and inspiring to
see you know we talked to Khloe so many
times this year and I did want to bring
up one really great great soundbite from
her where she's talking about
you know the effort she she puts into
her relationships and how she makes them
work take a listen
make it work I'm someone who I do like
to put my relationships as a priority
and I tried to make I really try to make
that work um and as long as people are
making the effort to do so mm-hmm I
think anything could work so it's a lot
of juggling she's juggling everything
and I think she does pryor prioritize
for relationships but she's also
starting to find balance which i think
is super healthy and that's why we are
Team Coco yes a 16 and Chloe is always
so honest when we interview her actually
we have an article up on the website
right now this was so interesting to me
Chloe I think said that the rest of the
family has made her kind of there there
couldn't servitor I'm not sure what the
right word is but they they've given her
the power if they need help in a medical
situation or something because they
think she's still competent I think he's
also coming out of that situation with
Lamar they saw firsthand how she handles
this under fire yeah she said that to
Health magazine I believe yeah we do
have that up on the site they're like
Chloe you here signing you my rights I
love this so much love coming in for
Coke yes yes the favorite right now
so many people saying it was her year
yes it was patrice says I love cocoa
actually says recipes kocktails with
khloé' yeah you know failure leads to
success we fail and then we find out
what we're good at speaking of success
speaking of kendall Jenner she also had
a very very good year banner year off of
what the biggest I think was that she
landed the coveted September Vogue cover
and looks so gorgeous look and it has
been so exciting this year to see her
really become a fashion model you know
she has said that you know people think
oh you got to step up with being on a
reality show I do think of course being
a Kardashian helped her but she didn't
have to work hard to get taken seriously
in the fashion industry and I think that
really happened for her this year she
was on the show less and less because
she was traveling so much for all the
modeling that she was doing and just
killing it all so turned 21 this year
hello oh my god to drink like I mean her
21 birthday party was lit was pretty lit
so many famous friends of course the
family was there she look at that there
it is she took over the to literally
hottest spots in LA right now catch and
delilah for a 21st birthday she wore a
dress a very glittery dress that she
said was inspired by Paris Hilton so
Kendall really doing her own thing you
know she she wants to make her own style
and make her oh yes girl look sparkly
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show of course
just so many big moments for Kendall and
getting to do it all with her best
friend her and Gigi Hadid out there just
slam question for you do you think 2017
is a year that Kendall finally finds
love ooh
so interesting right because we have so
many maybe bows for Kendall rumored
Jordan Clarkson rumored ASAP Rocky
I think that I want Kendall to keep
doing what she's doing which is dating
around don't settle down you see how
different her and Kylie are because
Kylie has been in this long-term
relationship with Tyga for quite a while
remember back before she was 18 we were
like caramel just standing around during
her think traveling see the world girl
yes that's what she's doing she's too
busy and then quickly we have to talk
about the last Kardashian sister of
course Kourtney
yeah and Scott Disick which has also
been a saga that's played out this year
things look good
or accordion Scott they were such a
question mark for so much of the of this
year you know still broken up we're now
hearing you know I mean that they are
getting along great what's gonna happen
for them in the future
it has been like we said though so great
to see Courtney do her thing and be
happy for herself I love seeing that and
Scott has really come back to you know
source tells us Scott is finally giving
Courtney what she's always wanted he's
been on his best behavior for the past
three months and he's been really
focused on the kids like there's so many
Instagram photos are currently on on his
account doesn't have Courtney in there
he's just like loving his children I
think he's spending a lot more time with
them too which is awesome to see you
know like the stalker that I am I was
watching an old episode of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians the other day and I
forgot man just how young Scott Disick
wasn't he was first on that show and
when he first had Mason he's a little
bit younger than Courtney I think he was
just in his early 20s maybe 24 so he's
been living this life for a while and I
think really what we've seen is just him
grow up you know he he's just matured
and we wish him nothing but the best but
I'm also I'm just glad for Courtney
there he has gotten the kids well today
they're actually celebrating the parents
are celebrating both Mason and rains
birthday today at Disneyland you can
hear and read all about it on ET online
but this family man keeping up with them
is so much work oh my gosh what a year
they've had honestly by the way you guys
tell us real quick we're see if we can
get any comments do you think that
Courtney should stick with Scott I'm
interested in this Latonya says Kendall
is gorgeous and again just so much love
coming in for Chloe let's make a couple
predictions what do you think we will
see in 2017 from the Kardashians well
I'm hoping Kim comes back I was we miss
you yeah I do I was going back through
all these tweets trying to find all the
clap backs and I was like man the
beginning this year
was so funny and so entertaining I've
been positive for both Kim and Kanye and
things took a turn I don't want to see
anybody kind of going through the
troubles that they are so I'm hoping
next year
Kim comes back Rob stays in limelight
Kim comes back Rob stays in the
limelight I want to see Rob get healthy
him in China have talked about how they
both they've said on Instagram they both
want to lose weight she wants to get
back to her pre-baby weight Rob just
wants to you know get healthy again he I
think has beaten the diabetes from last
thing I heard
just great but I want to see Rob now but
he's got this beautiful woman who loves
and he's got this baby yet physically
healthy because you got to be there for
your family and I think he can do it
with her help it's really sweet to see
them together be happy
that family is growing and the kids are
getting bigger so next year I think
we're gonna start seeing some more
personality out of all the children you
know Mason Disick you're an old man
watch my go we're ready for you little
mini beads in the making I don't know I
love it you guys thank you so much for
being here with us you can keep the
conversation with us going over on
Twitter and et is wrapping down all
things 2016 all this month on Facebook
tomorrow tell them what you got
Beyonce's biggest moments in 2016
do you have an hour it's gonna be fun do
them guys I mean lemonade lemonade
lemonade thanks so much for watching
everybody and have a great Thursday see
ya
[Music]
you
[Music]